[Music]
well good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you tuned in to see
the hearing in the senate armed services
committee today
and if you didn't you missed out but if
you did you may have been a little
surprised to see mark milley sitting
there you remember millie he's the
fleshy hood-eyed man who's the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff
he is also a national disgrace he's a
living insult to the military he
oversees that's not invective it's not
an insult it's objectively true
and yet somehow despite the overwhelming
evidence that mark milley is dishonest
incompetent partisan dishonorable mark
milley still has a highly prominent job
that's the amazing thing
and not only is mark milley still
employed at the very highest level he is
still lying and doing so with his
characteristic relish and enthusiasm
today for example with an entirely
straight face mark millie delivered an
impassioned lecture about the importance
of civilian control of the military
quote this country doesn't want generals
figuring out what orders we're going to
accept or do or not
that's not our job
oh really
is that so mark milly
isn't this the same mark millie who once
illegally seized personal control of our
country's nuclear arsenal
and then when that wasn't sufficient
promised to tip off the government of
china about future american military
operations and did all of this because
he didn't like his boss who unlike him
was yes a civilian elected by voters
yep that's the very same mark millie the
one lecturing you today about civilian
control of the military
it was all pretty amusing in a dark way
but it did make you wonder what is this
about
why is mark milley saying something so
obviously preposterous it's got to be
helping him in some way
and indeed it was helping him
what you watched in the senate hearing
today was pure blame shifting
joe biden's foreign policy is a
legitimate disaster nobody disputes that
but mark milley wants you to know that
none of it is his fault secretary of
defense lloyd austin wants you to know
that too so does the head of central
command general mackenzie all three of
them want to make it crystal clear that
the senile guy in the white house did
this it's his fault not theirs
it was joe biden they told us today who
forced american troops to leave
afghanistan before we evacuated all
american citizens
and because the pentagon reflexively in
every case follows every order to the
letter from the sitting president they
had no choice but to obey these crazy
decisions
watch them explain
general milley it's your testimony that
you recommended 2500 troops
uh approximately stay in afghanistan yes
my assessment was uh
back in the fall of 20 and remain
consistent throughout that we should
keep a steady state of 2500 and it could
bounce up to 3 500 maybe something like
that general mackenzie do you share that
assessment
senator i do share that assessment
president biden last month in an
interview with george stephanopoulos
said that no military leader advised him
to leave a small troop presence in
afghanistan did these officer and
general miller's recommendations get to
the president personally their input was
uh was received by the president and
considered by the president uh for sure
uh in terms of what they specifically
recommended senator they just as they
just said
uh
they're not gonna provide uh what they
recommended in confidence
are you following this
whale's officially coming off but whoa
what sleaze balls these guys are we told
joe biden to keep 2500 troops in the
country we demanded it
on the other hand because we are bound
by the ancient and sacred rules of
confidentiality we can't really tell you
what we told the president because that
would be wrong
these people so thoroughly deserve each
other
it is wonderful to see them rat one
another out which is exactly what they
proceeded to do for the entirety of
today's hearings
watch general mackenzie explain that
despite the fact that he personally
oversaw the disaster in afghanistan
actually he had nothing to do with it it
was all demented grandpa pulling the
strings from the white house
i won't share my personal recommendation
to the president but i will give you my
honest opinion and my honest opinion and
view shaped my recommendation i
recommended that we maintain 2500 troops
in afghanistan and i also recommended
earlier in the fall of 2020 that we
maintain 4500 at that time those are my
personal views i also have a view that
the withdrawal of those forces would
lead inevitably to the collapse of the
afghan military forces and eventually
the afghan government
what a dirt ball that guy is did you
just hear that i can't share my
recommendation quote but here was my
recommendation
take those medals off you don't deserve
them
until today the generals and their many
allies in government have been
undermining biden indirectly and far be
it for us to defend joe biden who
deserves no defense but it is a defense
of the american system which works well
when civilians control the military up
until today they have been leaking
biden's phone calls for example the
president of afghanistan that's illegal
but they did it anyway they'd be giving
nasty background quotes to their
stenographers at nbc news about what a
dope biden is all true but still they're
not allowed to do that
but today was different today's
performance took place in public it was
on the record and it was under oath and
in that performance they directly
contradicted the commander chief as a
reminder here's what joe biden was
saying just a few weeks ago on abc
if your top military advisors warned
against what's drawing on this timeline
they wanted you to keep about 2 500
troops no they didn't it was split
that wasn't true
that wasn't true
they didn't tell you that they wanted
troops to stay
no
not at not in terms of whether we were
going to get out in a time frame all
troops
they didn't argue against that so no one
no one told your military advisor did
not tell you no we should just keep 2500
troops it's been a stable situation for
the last several years we can do that we
can continue to do that no no one said
that to me that i can recall
oh
it's not a defense of any of them
they're all so awful and so undeserving
of leading this great country they
should not be in charge of this country
it's too good a country for people like
this
so here you have the generals claiming
they told biden the afghan withdrawal
would be a total disaster biden just in
the tape you saw says they did not tell
him that the question is who's lying
someone's lying joe biden doesn't know
who's lying he can't remember anything
he doesn't know what he had for lunch
here's what we know for sure though and
this is the point of today's hearings
and it's the point that matters going
forward no one in the pentagon's
leadership will ever be held accountable
for this the latest in a very long
string of colossal screw-ups that have
dramatically reduced american power and
prestige around the world and gotten a
ton of people killed
no one
this is unbelievable let's say you
worked at a nuclear power plant and one
day you had too many beers on your lunch
break and you fell asleep and the
reactor melted down and thousands died
and then you got a massive raise that's
pretty much what's happening here
the house of representatives just passed
a 776 billion defense budget how big is
that well
it's fully 24 billion dollars more than
even the white house requested in other
words congress just threw a little extra
for a job well done a bonus for the
generals who left 80 billion dollars
worth of american military equipment for
the taliban to use good work guys
so it's official now no one will ever be
punished for any of it not for
abandoning bagram air base that was
idiotic everyone knew it they did it
anyway not for leaving american citizens
behind as they fled
not for leaving our troops exposed to
the attack that killed 13 young american
servicemen not for the drone strike that
blew up children the one they lied about
for weeks
the people who did these things are in
great shape tonight they will retire
exactly when they feel like retiring at
which point they will get full benefits
and jobs at lockheed
that's how our system now works
it's very very frustrating
not because
recrimination is good but because in
order to function a system has to be
accountable
and as of tonight there's only one man
in the entire u.s government who is
being punished for the failure the
catastrophic failure in afghanistan just
one man
his name is stu sheller he is lieutenant
colonel in the united states marine
corps he he's an honorable and honest
man he is also blameless sheller had no
role in any of these decisions what was
his crime his crime was criticizing
those decisions in august he posted this
video on the internet
if an o5 battalion commander has uh the
simplest live fire incident eo complaint
boom fired but we have a secretary of
defense that testified to congress in
may that the afghan national security
force could withstand the taliban
advance we have chairmans of joint chief
who the command is a member of that
who's supposed to advise on military
policy we have a marine
combatant commander
all of these people are supposed to
advise and i'm not saying we've got to
be in the
in afghanistan forever but i am saying
did any of you throw your rank on the
table and say hey it's a bad idea to
evacuate bagram airfield the strategic
air barriers before we evacuate everyone
so that's an honorable man you just saw
on the screen that's a man who's in it
for the right reasons not to get
promoted or work at lockheed but because
he cares about the country and wants to
defend it there's a man who believed in
his superiors who is not cynical who is
genuinely confused by his superiors
unwillingness to admit their own error
his confusion comes from decency
and almost immediately his superiors
reacted to that video they didn't
apologize for the disaster they didn't
explain why they did what they did they
punished sheller
they relieved him of his command and
they told him to shut up and stop
talking but he didn't stop talking
here's how he responded
to recap my position in the fallout of
afghanistan i demanded accountability my
senior leaders i stated then that i
understood
that i might lose my
battalion commander c my retirement and
my family stability as it has played out
i have in fact lost all three of those
things
would i do it again
i don't know my name is lieutenant
colonel stewart sheller
and i was the only officer in the entire
american coalition fired in the debacle
of afghanistan fallout
i acknowledge that i should have been
fired
however
the hypocrisy of the general officers
who are not being held to the same
standard is a microcosm for the entire
problem that is going to bring down the
great institutions of this republic that
we love
so that's the man you want serving in
your officer corps in a serious country
a person who takes his job seriously
who's patriotic who's honest who demands
accountability and before you say well
it's the military they don't have
freedom of speech you're not allowed to
give a political statement two points
one that was not an explicitly political
statement in contrast 2.2 the endless
number of openly partisan statements
from the leaders of the pentagon mark
milley
was openly thrilled by the election of
joe biden
was he punished for that no he was
elevated and congress again just
rewarded him and the entire leadership
of the u.s military with 24 extra
billion dollars
but stu sheller for telling the truth
well
here's what happened to him
military brass forced stu sheller to
undergo a psychological evaluation
because only a crazy person would ask
for accountability after the disaster in
afghanistan
and then when he wouldn't admit he was
crazy they threw him in prison
in jail where he sits tonight
scheller's father just released this
statement explaining that his son is now
behind bars with violent criminals and
how long is he there he's there
indefinitely this is happening tonight
in america here's a quote from his
father all our son did is ask the
question that everybody was asking
themselves but they were too scared to
speak out loud he was asking for
accountability in fact i think he even
asked for an apology that we made
mistakes but they couldn't do that which
is mind-blowing they had a gag order on
him and asked him not to speak he did
speak and they incarcerated him they
don't know what to do with him
it's one of the worst stories
of our time and there are a lot of bad
stories right now hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else